I think we're gonna have a vaccine by
the end of the year now
the doctors would say well you shouldn't
say that I'll say what I think I've met
with the heads of the big companies
these are great companies yeah I think
we're gonna have a vaccine much sooner
rather than later
so one of the headlines from last night
President Trump predicting a vaccine by
the end of this year meanwhile the CEO
of a company behind the possible
treatment remedy severe telling CBS News
that drug starts arriving in hospitals
this week I want to bring in dr. RG Shaw
director of the Harvard Global Health
Institute and doc nice to see you again
and good afternoon to you vaccine by the
end of the year is it possible yeah well
so bill first of all thanks for having
me back on you know that would be great
and I think we're all gonna hope I think
it's gonna be a long shot together by
the end of this year but 2021 sometime
hopefully earlier on will be great it's
really optimistic to think we can get it
by January when I'm looking at this
science that the science is better now
but it was during the HIV fight it's
better now argue believe in a bowl even
three years ago when you've got all
hands on deck from all these countries
around the world why not consider the
possibility of it being fast-tracked
oh absolutely remember it takes years to
make vaccines in general so anything
that's like 9 12 18 months is super
fast-tracked the only thing I would say
is we've never built a corona virus
vaccine before this is our first time as
humanity do I think we can do it I do
all hands are on deck but we just have
to plan for the possibility that it may
take a little while because we've never
done this before
Oxford University is on this is you know
Pfizer Johnson & Johnson Oxford said
over the weekend that they will know if
their vaccine is effective in early June
that's a month away that's pretty fast
it is they're gonna they're doing
they're getting into Phase two trials I
look I don't mean to be the downer on
this I'm the enthusiast I just don't
want to over promise and under deliver
and we'd be much better if we hope for
January but plan for June or September
of 2021 and if we get surprised it'd be
awesome okay yeah we'll take that it
would be awesome strong language you
have about the CDC how come what do you
think's going on there I don't you know
I know I feel terrible because as a
public health
person I've always loved and admired the
CDC they have to spend a wall in this
entire time they have their advice has
not been on time and an evidence base
they're not giving us the data we need I
think we need to really take a hard look
at what's happening at the CDC and why
are they not performing as we expect you
know I saw some of your comments you
don't like the leadership down there in
Atlanta that's that's what I take away
from what you're saying that you know
sorry look I don't know what's going on
to be perfectly honest what I can tell
the first test is they're not perform
what's that the first test failed yeah
the first test failed they've put out
recommendations that I've been slow they
have not been keeping up on the data for
four weeks they took the weekend off on
updating what was happening with the
pandemic you don't take weekends off in
the benefit middle of a pandemic so
they've been a lot of issues and I don't
understand what's going on but we got to
get the bus so we will see on that in
the meantime there's a report of a South
Korea suggestion you cannot get it for a
second time have you seen that study and
what do you think yeah look this is this
is heading in the right direction we've
been we have wanted to be sure that once
you're infected and get better we would
love to make sure that you're not you're
immune and you can't get reinfected
we've had a few instances of people
testing positive again more and more the
evidence is coming back those people are
not reinfected maybe we're just picking
up a fragment of the virus and that
hopefully that you really do get
immunity after you've been infected let
me try and just squeeze one more
question and here back here in the US
what what is your feeling about the
reopening as the economies and these
governors try engage that these
decisions down you know we all want to
reopen I get the feeling and I totally
am sympathetic I think the president's
guidelines for opening up America again
are evidence base and science-based
I want governors to use those guidelines
and if they meet the guidelines I think
they should open but not all the
governors do not all the states do and
some of them are going against the
president's guidelines and that makes me
really nervous
dr. good luck to you okay and I hope you
come back in a matter of days of a week
or maybe even soon so much that dr.
jotte thank you nice to see you again